dur d'être petit le petit village de
druides et belle fontana dans l'yonne
vient d'être privé des services de deux
de ce pompier bénévole petit feu il leur
manque de centimètres pour atteindre la
taille réglementaire
jamie pour les intimes
[Musique]
je suis maire de druides et
bellefontaine depuis le 5 octobre 1991
mais je connais le village depuis très
longtemps puisque je suis venue pour la
première fois en 1932
à cette époque le village comptait 550
habitants où iront passer des 50
exploitations agricoles d'un nombreux
commerçants cinq cafés
c'était un village actifs en 1943 les
rails de notre chemin de fer furetant
lever plus de chemin de fer actuellement
comme dans tous les pays ruraux la crise
l'emploi
la concentration des fermes a fait
disparaître une grande partie de la
population puisque nous sommes environ
actuellement 300 habitants à druyes
[Musique]
parmi les activités qui fonctionnent
bien a brui figure le corps des sapeurs
pompiers volontaires
or on veut départementalisée les
services incendie
en foi de quoi j'ai reçu fin juillet une
circulaire dont je vous lis la première
ligne les pompiers volontaires devraient
avoir une taille égale ou supérieure à
un mètre soixante eh oui je ne fais km
56 emon adjoints 1 m 58
nous ne sommes plus dans la légalité
depuis près de 19 ans bien entendu
l'essentiel des activités de bruit ce ne
sont pas les pompiers traditionnellement
nous avons l'agriculture mais une telle
débauche de sites et de monuments
historiques a visité que notre grand
espoir c'est le tourisme
nous avons le château de bruit de la fin
du xiième siècle c'est l'un des châteaux
fardeau les mieux conservés de cette
époque
nous avons une église romane du 12e
siècle
[Musique]
également le château du boulet
d'attentes des 16 et 17ème siècles
nous avons la maison du capitaine quoi
yen il fut le premier décoré de la
légion d'honneur par l'empereur napoléon
1er est bien lui aussi avait des
problèmes de taille comme nos pompiers
il mesurait 1 m 56 et il s'est mis un
jeu de cartes dans cette chaussure pour
arriver à faire la taille nécessaire
pour entrer dans l'armée impériale et
nous avons surtout l'eau comme son nom l
indique d'huile à bellefontaine
ce sont plus de 100 source un lac une
rivière une rivière à brochets de plus
et croyez-moi j'empêche dogon du brochet
dans la rivière de bruit voilà ce qu'il
en reste de nos belles fontaines quatre
années consécutives du 15 juillet au 15
décembre approximativement plus une
goutte d'eau dans le pays
plus une goutte d'eau
mais pourquoi l'eau a disparu il ya
certainement plusieurs facteurs d'abord
la sécheresse et d'un autre côté une
inadéquation des cultures qui a fait que
des drainages ont été faits en amont de
druyes des drainages d irrigation et des
pompages direct sur les nappes
donc c'est la faute aux agriculteurs ah
non ah non non il n'est pas du tout
question d'attaquer les agriculteurs ja
je mets en doute plutôt les directives
qui leur sont données pour la mise en
culture des terres de par exemple les
maïs les maïs ici ce n'est pas un pays à
maïs le maïs a besoin d'énormément daube
et on leur fait cultiver du maïs on leur
demande de faire du maïs
voilà la raison et mais on ne s'occupe
pas en lieu de savoir si ici c'est un
pays ami ici c'est un pays à marguerite
ou si c'est un pays à rhododendrons mais
qu'est ce qui les oblige c'est
l'économie nationale c'est l'ouverture
des marchés sur l'étranger on a besoin
de maïs on a besoin de ceux ci on a
besoin de cela sans savoir si la terre
est calcaire et nous nous n'avons plus
d'eau alors que faire que faire c'est la
mort du pays
nous sommes que des pompiers communaux
des pompiers bénévoles volontaires et au
niveau des communes nous faisons à
d'autres petits travaux
aujourd'hui par exemple un didier
jusqu'à présent nous avions des rapports
et voisins lorsque par exemple une
personne voyez l'un des pompiers le plus
proche et lui disais le soir on partait
le fer avec la départementalisation
cette personne devra faire le 18 le 18
ans vers un télex au chef-lieu de canton
qui lui nous rappellera pour nous
signaler un nid à faire le soir il
faudra passer par auxerre et à ce moment
là c'est pas sûr que l'on puisse
continuer de travailler pour les
communes et sur des petites communes
comme ça c'est surtout au niveau d'entre
elles
on se connaît tous alors derrière cette
histoire de taille ce qui nous inquiète
c'est que nous voyons une volonté de
nous professionnaliser de façon à nous
demander en renfort lé week end surtout
au niveau des axes routiers ou les
professionnels commencent à être débordé
je crains que l'équipe que j'ai à
l'heure actuelle ne soit plus d'accord
en somme notre grand tort c'est d'être
petit nous avons l'impression d'être
enserré dans une réglementation qui nous
sclérose totalement étant donné que nous
sommes d'un village historique
nous sommes totalement sous la coupe des
bâtiments de france qui nous amène une
aide précieuse pour la conservation de
notre patrimoine mais qui nous impose
par ailleurs des obligations
assez ennuyeuse un petit exemple pour
ouvrir une simple fenêtre cela deviendra
un véritable problème
un autre exemple concret cet ancien
moulin qui a été transformé en salle des
fêtes sous prétexte que nous allions
l'eau du lac à notre porte
on nous a fortement conseillé pour le
chauffage et pour l'aération les
fenêtres n'ouvrant pas une pompe à
chaleur mais depuis quatre ans plus tôt
peut-on pas chaleur peu de chauffage
plus des rations donc plus de salle des
fêtes
[Musique]
prenez un dernier exemple nous y sommes
un village touristique où plus de dix
mille personnes de tourisme populaire
viennent visiter notre site
nous avons demandé licence touristique
nous n'avons pas même un petit café avec
un tabac pour leur offrir un peu de
repos cela nous a été refusé trois fois
parce que nous sommes trop petits
je trouve que c'est relativement
scandaleux
et le problème que je viens d'évoquer
doivent trouver on august et surtout le
problème de l'eau quatre ans c'est trop
et si nous n'avons plus d'eau il n'y
aura plus de bruit les belles fontaines
dont il existera plus ce n'est pas parce
que nous sommes petits nous avons le
droit de mourir
[Musique]
t'es pas trop petit mon ami tu es battre
au petit oui on a toujours besoin d'un
plus petit que soi
ce dicton serait-il bon à jeter au feu
mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire le courage aux cm et ils on va
toujours aller se faire la courte
échelle mais je m'enflamme je m'en fous
pouviez je m'enflamme bon il n'y a pas
le feu
y'a pas le feu mais ça va chauffer sous
les casques attention
[Musique]